I chose to delete this edge here.
I started by coloring this vertex green,
and
then reasoning about what colors
the other vertices might be.
Assuming that I don't delete this edge,
this vertex here has to be orange.
And assuming that I don't delete this
edge here, this one has to be green.
And assuming I don't delete this edge
here, this one has to be orange again.
And that's okay, because this edge here
has one green and one orange vertex.
This vertex here must be green,
since both of its neighbors are orange.
This last vertex here has both green and
orange neighbors, so
I need to delete one of its edges.
I picked this edge to delete,
and I colored it orange.